we got the story from timcast.com all
three men found guilty of murder in
ahmed arbury case this is the story
about
the a man who had gone to this
neighborhood several times he had
entered a building on multiple occasions
uh i believe he was actually a a felony
suspect is that was it those that was in
the in the trial i think that even the
prosecution said yes oh yeah a felony
suspect burglary suspect in this
instance yeah yeah well so what so this
is from actual justice warrior he had
tweeted that in the case
the issue was
they all agreed that he was actually
suspected of committing burglaries oh
the police were going door-to-door but
not that
they were having a photo of the guy
right yeah but not that day
and so the issue was they did not have
actual knowledge of anything he had he
had done it that day but i don't i'll
give you the context real quick all
three men were found guilty and the
craziest thing about it is
the third guy
he was just following in his car and
filming what was happening and then he
public he gave the footage like hey look
and they prosecuted this guy's going to
prison for the rest of his life for
filming this so you're we're getting a
lot of conservatives first of all the
entire entirety of the left is cheering
when they announced the verdict a guy in
the courtroom was like woo and then the
judge was like get him out of my
courtroom no outbursts and all people
outside are cheering and celebrating
which is funny considering they just
said the justice system was broken
because of written house but they're
cheering for it and then i see a bunch
of conservatives cheering for it and i'm
like i think y'all are wrong on this one
in in a certain sense
legally speaking on the law yep that
jerry got it right the judge gave him
instructions these guys did not have a
right to get in their trucks grab a
shotgun and go chase down some dudes
surround him but there's a lot of of
context here that says to me
i think these these i think the two guys
that mcmichaels these are the two guys
who are directly involved with getting
their vehicle in the gun and then
confronting the father and the son
father and the son i believe they
deserve charges i don't know if you know
sending them for decades in prison makes
sense but they should have been charged
for a lot of for you know on something
the third guy who was just filming i
mean this is i just so was the ruling
then that he was part of the pursuit is
that the surrounding part of that but it
was they had also charged him with
aggravated assault yeah uh using his
pickup truck which doesn't mean you have
to cause injury it means you put someone
else in fear of injury right uh so
it wasn't just that he was filming it's
it's
the aggravated assault which is a felony
and that's then he died so it's felony
murder which only emerges
i think on the law this is the right
ruling and i think that's what most
people are saying so i'll just put it
this way the the dude was a burglary
suspect that was would not uh up for can
he was not uh contested
but you have in the video that came out
two via i think it's two vehicles or
maybe just a truck and aubry is seen
running towards that truck but you got a
guy following behind him so he's not
gonna turn around he's got to run
towards the guy with the shotgun and
i'll tell you this
between two trucks in fairness he's not
limited to the street oh you could run
to the right right
350 degrees of other directions right he
could run in and it's not like the
trucks went up on the lawns of
properties chasing but if they had been
following him for for several minutes he
knew they were following him in his mind
he may have been like i can't get away
from these guys this guy's holding a
shotgun my only way out of this is to
fight back well maybe but that's not an
element of the crimes against them right
uh if he had gotten the gun and shot
them and been charged with shooting them
and he raised the legal defense of
self-defense then the reasonableness of
his perception would be relevant but
it's it's not relevant with respect to
these criminal charges what would your
analysis be given given that were the
case well it's it's over playing
hypothetically yeah no it's what
complicates it is he wasn't just someone
recreationally jogging i mean we know
this
you'd have to erase your mind of
everything else around him that but he
was in the home i know they are and
that's
you know that just makes proper legal
analysis more complicated because
there's a lot of misinformation
disinformation and if you believe that
stuff you come to a different outcome
but this guy was in that home repeatedly
in the middle of the night this is not
somebody recreationally visiting a
construction site right and and there
had been burglaries there had been
robberies a gun had been done yeah not
even a month prior and when when when we
say that the mcmichaels didn't know
exactly what he was doing that day they
knew the other stuff and the other stuff
can play a role in your assessment of
probable cause if a police officer had
seen those videos of him there those
other times and then saw him apparently
leaving the building again that day the
police officer is not required to
pretend he doesn't know that past
experience those past events he's
allowed to consider that in coming to a
determination a probable cause on that
day even if he didn't see explicitly
burglar-like activity that they he's
seen burglar-like activity from this guy
on this property on previous exchange so
let me ask you and i think the answer's
obvious but you being the attorney on
self-defense if travis mcmichael
who has not been convicted on all counts
if he actually was a police officer who
did the exact same thing
what would have happened
he would never been charged never never
they wouldn't even bring charges no and
so so here's here's the crazy thing
there's a there's a vehicle behind ahmed
armory so i can certainly understand why
he's like you know these guys are after
me no i don't think he was a good dude i
think he had you know male intent but
you know don't surround people like if
you're you're i i can certainly
understand why but of course the defense
was that they weren't the defense was
there was no coordination between those
two vehicles right so they weren't like
a pack of walls surrounding somebody
look i i i get it but i also feel like
you know just i think about what i would
be doing if i was running down the
street and then a car comes up behind me
in cars in front of me
so we can we can listen right but again
we're confusing it because you have to
think what would i be doing if that
happened to me and i was engaged in
felony burglary behavior
right you know why they're following you
you're not a recreational jogger who's
suddenly being approached by men with
shotguns that's not what's happening no
no all right so you're saying there's a
reason the hands don't go up and it's
hey guys
in the context of these guys not being
law enforcement
like this guy's going to fight but
here's what i'm getting too ahmed arbury
runs i think he would have fought if
they were law enforcement oh i agree i
agree so i think what he's getting at is
that this guy
didn't want to be stopped right for
night for anybody because of what ran to
the right from the around the right side
of the truck got around it and then
flanked left
grabbed the shotgun from travis
mcmichael they fought over it
a shot was fired hitting on at arbory
and he died now i want to stop and i
want to give you the real context in a
more
in the spirit of what i think is a fair
assessment
the the media the left will tell you and
that's what they did say that a bunch of
racists got in a pickup truck and chased
down a jogger and lynched him which is a
psychotic
lie what actually happened a couple
local guys who had been hearing reports
about burglaries from the police
heard this guy was spotted in their
neighborhood again again again a gun had
been stolen about a month earlier
they say hey we got to figure out who
this guy is we got to check them out
we're going to work they probably didn't
think anything other than we got to stop
this guy what does that mean it could
mean nothing it could be like let's just
get in our car and go after them
actually hold on hold on so so they they
they they knew a gun was stolen
that's why travis mcmichael had a
shotgun
hey someone stole a gun if he's got a
gun we could be in trouble and if we try
and say hey what are you doing here and
even try and talk to him he could have a
gun
when they stop their truck and as you
argue the defense argue there's no
coordination he gets out with a shotgun
he is legally allowed to keep and bear
arms
when ahmed arbury ran around the truck
and then grabbed the gun and fought with
them there was now dual possession of
that weapon
in the fight a shotgun blast killed
ahmed armory so i look at that and i'm
like man i understand the letter of the
law they got the conviction but doesn't
it feel like something doesn't make
sense or doesn't add up properly the
narrative of the mainstream media is a
lie of course does this mean the
provocation argument kind of that we
were talking about in kyle rittenhouse
uh well the prosecution did raise the
issue of provocation in her closing
statement or was it a major part of the
trial i think
and suddenly i lost my train of thought
um
go ahead temino did the guy watch the
shot i was throwing it back to you
the guy with the shotgun brandished the
shotgun he was holding it uh i think he
was just holding it and then ahmed aubry
looked oh i remember what i was going to
say so he's in front of the truck to the
left sorry just and then almond army
goes around it and can't actually see
travis mcmichael and then comes around
in the front and attacks him and
charges him it's unknown whether
mcmichael ever brandished
well it's disputed the video is very
fuzzy at that point and there's parts
where they're obscured by the truck in
front so you can't really see what's
happening but of course either way it
has to prove guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt but i don't think it matters
because if he's pointing at that point
he's being charged by someone yeah
arbory is on camera
going around the car and at this point
there is no gun pointed at him and he
chooses then to turn left and engage
travis mcmichael
so it's it's much more complicated than
malice murder and felony murder but they
just said you know across the board so
here's here's the thing i want to make
clear because there's obviously a lot of
emotions around this it's a racially
energized case i don't care about these
guys getting convicted and going to
prison on any kind of personal level i
don't know these people they're not
friends of mine they weren't my client
what happens to them is a very little
consequence to me on any kind of
personal level but professionally i care
a lot about the legal process and i care
a lot about due process and if they're
going to get convicted it ought to be
done the right way and that didn't
happen here because the whole case
rested on this citizens arrest statute
and your interpretation of it there were
two possible interpretations lawyers in
that courtroom and me myself outside the
courtroom with lots of other lawyers we
in good faith argued different different
positions on that citizens arrest law
the judge wasn't sure exactly what it
meant when all the legal experts can't
decide on what it means
someone has to make the call you can't
have an a version and a b version one of
which favors the prosecution one of
which favors the defense and whichever
one is chosen decides the whole case and
both parties know that the prosecution
knows oh my gosh if i don't get my
version i lose this trial these guys
walk well and the defense knows if we
don't get our version our clients are
going to get convicted there's no other
possible outcome so somebody has to
decide which version is the jury going
to get and that's the responsibility of
the judge in this case real quick what
are these rights yeah i was gonna same
thing yeah
one of the virgins one of the virgins
ah
i guess there should be 72 of those
right
essentially one of the versions is that
the citizens arrest could only be lawful
if everything was contemporaneous and
they had essentially perfect knowledge
that a felony burglary had occurred and
of course the defense never claimed
either of those things because
that didn't exist right they didn't know
for a fact that he'd committed felony
burglary and the the felony felony
burglary like conduct they were aware of
was not contemporaneous with their
efforts to arrest him what does that
mean contemporaneous happening at the
same time right so they had they had
evidence of felony like behavior but it
was from a week earlier two weeks ago so
it's like it's like they didn't see him
walk up smash the window go in and grab
a bunch of stuff that is the state
position that's what they would have had
in that moment to to make the citizens
uh arrest lawful that's the state
position and if that position is
accepted well then they're convicted
because they don't have any of that yeah
the defense position is well no it's the
knowledge is first of all doesn't have
to be absolute doesn't have to be in his
presence because he was an apparent
felon in flight the standard should be
probable cause that's what the statute
says probable cause not certainty and
probable cause can be based on knowledge
not gained only in that moment but prior
knowledge that you're aware of
surveillance video of the guy in the
house that you've seen that's part of
your knowledge base it's part of why you
believe it's probable
that he's now also committing a felony
burglary if you have that definition
that favors the defense it's probably an
acquittal so these two competing
versions one wins for the state one wins
for the defense the judge had his duty
was to make a call look
we don't know which one of these really
should apply but on the judge i decide
what the law is going to be as presented
to the jury now when he makes a decision
later on he might be reversed appellate
court might say no you chose a it should
have been b or the reverse
but it's also true
that
there's only one way to actually make
that decision because there's a legal
doctrine called the doctrine of lenity
and it says if a statute is ambiguous in
criminal law
the benefit of the doubt is always given
to the defense
not to the state so because the state
drafted the law the state passed the law
the state was in control of how
unambiguously that statute was written
you can't hold that against the
defendant so the judge was going to pick
one of those versions under the doctrine
of lenity he would be obliged to pick
the version that favored the defense and
then we're looking at acquittals for
these guys and the city would have
burned to the ground right yeah maybe
many cities so he decided well i'm not
going to make that decision so he
punches i'm not going to do my job i'm
going to take the ambiguous version both
options give them to the jury and let
them decide and that's not the job of
the jury the crazy thing to me is um you
know like i i tweeted basically about
you know i write your article i did a
video on it and i tweeted like this
could result in an appeal is that fair
to say they'll they'll oh yeah there's
fertile ground for appeal here but right
people need to keep in mind appeals i
like to say appeals are for losers
um and that's technically true right
you're only appealing literally
that's right obviously here's
the interesting thing here for one i
mean there could be but things do get
overturned
look looking at this
you have kyle rittenhouse who was
fleeing
and you have ahmed arbury who was
engaging
you can argue that by putting the pickup
truck there and then having behind him
that you know it was a fight-or-flight
reflex but he didn't have to attack them
and go for the gun
so i i was thinking about that in
regards to your previous statements on
kyle rittenhouse about how the mentality
of anthony huber for instance has no
bearing on the self-defense right of
kyle rittenhouse anthony huber could
believe he stopped being a mass shooter
but he's still threatening kyle who has
a right to self-defense right in this
instance i'm curious about
the different potentialities here
i mean just what's your assessment on
was michael defending it all comes back
to that citizen's arrest law if you
believe the citizens arrest was unlawful
well then it makes sense that arbory
would defend himself and he would have a
right to defend himself against an
unlawful arrest but let's let me ask you
something i mean is this whole case
seems to be an issue of the context
provided by the mcmichaels what if they
just said we just happen to be standing
there legally bearing arms and you
attacked me
well we of course we know that's not
true because they gave statements to the
police at the scene that's why they were
it's the con so so these guys oh if
these guys had just kept their mouth
shut that wouldn't you couldn't have had
a process and then in a video
yeah so that guy released the video
thinking it would exonerate that they
they gave it all they gave the
statements and months went by i mean the
the prosecutor the original prosecutor
passed on charges yeah i mean he
actually wrote a memo saying no this was
lawful citizen's arrest and therefore
everything is you know was within the
boundaries of the law it was political
the charges came back because there was
political outrage
well again after the video came out this
is a money-making opportunity for some
people that's right this is the point
that i keep bringing it back to
and
we now live in a society that is
governed by viral videos whatever the
last viral video that came out is now
the new discussion and if it comes out
remember george floyd started with a
viral video um the what are they the
central park karen which actually turned
out to be false that started with a
video a very selectively edited video
which the guy who posted it actually
later debunked on his own facebook
because he said he did provoke her i
said he was gonna take it he said he was
gonna take her dog and then she freaks
out thinking that the stranger's about
to take my dog so the problem though
that we have in society is that we now
live in a mass surveillance society
but george orwell who got a lot right
got this wrong it's not big brother
that's the only one that's in on the
game of mass surveillance it's everyone
little brother also severely each out
right lots of little brothers lots of
little sisters my and so the question
then becomes what do we do with all this
kyle rittenhouse if there were no video
he would be in jail for the rest of his
life yep
because it would be his word against the
word of the other people in that mob and
it would be very very hard for him to
get off without that video but
with these guys the mcmichaels they're
going to jail because of video my
understanding is that um i could be
wrong it's been a while it's been almost
two years now but the uh the guy was his
name brady or something um brian or
something the third guy yeah the third
guy he released the video because i
think people in the community were
calling him murderers and he was like no
like look it was it was self-defense
i'll show you the video and then
everyone was like whoa
hey and that's one of those videos where
people will see what they want to see in
that video and you will never change
anybody's mind some people see that
video and they see
a a felony suspect charging a man who
has a shotgun in his hands fighting that
man for a shotgun and dying in the
effort and by the way when they showed
those gruesome wound scenes of on arbory
those are the same wounds that the
michaels would have feared they would
have suffered if he had gotten control
of that shotgun right it's exactly the
same thing but other people look at that
video and what they see is they see a
rosenbaum they see a black man who was
chased by a bunch of rednecks and is
desperately fighting for his life
because it fits a narrative right and
what if uh do you uh i think there's no
point asking if we you know what aubry
would have done with the gun but
considering he went for the shotgun and
is visibly fighting for it
what would have happened if aubry got
the gun
and shot them
he would be charged and it would
wouldn't be pressed if i was his
attorney i'd be arguing self-defense
yeah yeah but i don't think it would be
in the press nobody would know about it
it would not be new well no small
georgian community you don't know i mean
if george zimmerman had been killed by
trayvon martin we never would have heard
about the case right right i thought
that would be a non-event it would just
be another
but i also i also think it's fair to say
that if they didn't go out there with
the shotgun we also wouldn't be hearing
about this case because a fight would
have broken out that would have been the
end of it but you could say that for any
case well it's it's it's true and i want
to stress people have a right to keep
and bear arms it's not every case i
disagree with that so i i think there's
a lot of debate to be had around the
nature of the citizen's law statute
whether this judge did his job and i
believe he did not i i just mean that um
but that doesn't mean these guys
exercise in any case that doesn't mean
these guys didn't exercise poor judgment
that was poor judgment by the way
written house also exercised poor
judgment if i had a 17 year old son i
would not say hey a good idea let's uh
you know take the ar go down to the
right
but poor judgment's not a crime right i
mean as a guy who's got an ex-wife thank
god poor judgment is not a crime so
they're not charged with that they're
charged with specific offenses with
specific elements and specific
defenses with specific elements and one
of those is citizen's arrest and how
that law is supposed to be applied and
when you just give the jury the job of
deciding how the law works the only
non-experts in the courtroom by the way
the courtroom is full of lawyers there's
three prosecutors there's
six defense attorneys and a judge and
none of them can figure out what the
statute's actually supposed to mean but
we're going to let 12 jurors untrained
in the law right do that job let me ask
you uh in your opinion based on the
facts of the case do you think
these men should have been convicted
you know i i
my view of justice is different i i
don't think about the outcomes per se i
don't really care about the outcomes per
se in my view justice is about the
process
not about the outcome well
i'm asking because i was going to ask
you then on on the judge's ruling so the
first thing i want to understand is you
know based on your understanding of the
case and the law as you've read it
do you think it should have been an
acquittal or
i think there was reasonable doubt that
they had probable cause
to try to make a citizen's right and by
the way just
you lean towards an acquittal is what
you're saying
yes but i don't want people to
misunderstand i don't by that i i don't
mean like i think it's more likely than
not that they had probable cause but
that's not the legal standard the
standard isn't whether they were
probably right the standard is
is there a reasonable doubt that they
could have been right do they you know
could they
the math gets complicated but could they
have had a 51 belief that he was a
felony burglary suspect
is that enough by a reasonable doubt
there is a very tiny belief that they
might have had probable cause should be
sufficient for an acquittal the reason i
ask is
do you have like so you've mentioned the
judge didn't do his job in defining and
instructing properly do you have a view
of how it should have been instructed
yes so my reading of the statute favors
the defense
because there's basically
it's amazing how ambiguous it is because
it's only two sentences so it's not like
in the in the kyle rittenhouse case they
had that gun statute where you had to
refer to this other statute and then you
had to refer to two other statutes
beyond that and it got very kind of well
in some sense it's complicated
this is only a two sentence statute but
the first sentence talks about kind of
citizen's arrest generally and it says
you have to have immediate knowledge or
presence and the second sentence speaks
specifically to a felon in flight and
there it says probable cause and some
people believe you got to read those two
together
and others my position is you have to
read them separately because it doesn't
make any sense to read them together so
the way i read it it says look for
citizens arrest generally and that means
for like misdemeanors like shoplifting
for you know the smallest arrestable
offense you have to have
presence or immediate knowledge
that's 100 certainty you saw it happen
right that's not probable cause that's
not you think it's likely it happened
you saw it happen that happened in your
presence you have immediate knowledge
to believe that that's if you have you
start with a hundred percent that's the
requirement but then if it's a felony in
pursuit you also have to have 51 percent
i mean you're already at 100. can i i
want to read it for this is from your
article from legal insurrection it says
that the two sentences are a private
person may arrest an offender if the
offense is committed in his presence or
within his immediate knowledge if the
offense is a felony and the offender is
escaping or attempting to escape a
private person may arrest him upon
reasonable and probable grounds of
suspicion so how i read that is
generally like even for a misdemeanor if
you want to arrest somebody for a
misdemeanor you have to have absolute
knowledge presence or immediate
knowledge you saw them shoplift that
item
but for the special circumstance of a
felon in flight
in that case it's then probable cause 51
is certain because and that makes sense
to me because we're treating them
differently look an arrest is a profound
constraint of your liberty right this
makes your assessment makes total sense
yeah but before we let you and by the
way that applies to cops the standard
for cops is if they want to arrest
somebody for a misdemeanor they have to
have seen it they don't have to have
seen it for a felony right so this
actually if if we put these two
requirements together what we're
actually saying is it's it's
it's harder to arrest somebody who's a
felon in pursuit than it is to a
wrestler
wait wait wait tim just put it back in
in a common sense right couldn't this
isn't this also just the situation of
hey stop that guy yeah right hey stop
that guy he stole a purse hey stop that
guy he stole my phone that's right
that's what i was saying that's 50 and
so right so i didn't see him steal the
phone but i'm hearing someone say hey
this guy stole my phone stop that guy
you you mean if you want to make that
legal you made a good point about you
know this guy who is a
burglary suspect was entering this home
repeatedly when you operate from the
leftists false narrative that this guy
was just jogging the story's very
different a couple rednecks accused a
jogger of a crime he didn't commit and
then confronted with a shotgun he
defended himself when you know all the
facts you know that these guys were
scared because you know as i mentioned a
gun had been stolen there had been
burglaries you guys mentioned that the
police had actually handed out his photo
is that what they did
i forget if they were showing i think
they were showing photos around from the
video they were showing the video yeah
the video from uh when he was inside the
home in the middle of the night right so
maybe not like a mug shot right if you
see this guy in the neighborhood call us
because we have a video there was
reporting though that one of the i
believe was the older mcmichael had
known of our berry from a previous
investigation but he didn't connect the
dots uh yeah so
so arbory had been
he had brought a gun to school i believe
it was a felony conviction oh wow uh so
he he was an adult who went to some
school event so he was volunteering it
was like a football game yeah yeah yeah
i remember that i i forget the status of
it was convicted of the felony or if it
was expunged or i don't remember the
details so i don't want to overstate it
but
it was a felony charge for sure because
he brought the gun and then he fought
the cops when they tried to arrest him
for having the gun to school it was a
big mess and the prosecutor's office
investigated that event and the
investigator was greg mcmichaels so he
they'd had some exposure to each other
right right but there's no evidence that
at the time of this day when arbory was
shot that greg michaels recognized him
does that make sense
i want to break down this this this uh
which would have made a huge difference
by the way because that would have been
a huge contributor to probably cause and
reason to feel i i i always remember
that because that's getting these two
sentences real quick just very simply a
private person may arrest an offender if
the offense is committed in his presence
or within his immediate knowledge if the
offense is a felony and the offender is
escaping or attempting to escape a
private person may arrest him upon
reasonable and probable grounds of
suspicion i think your assessment is
very reasonable to put it simply if
someone commits a misdemeanor you have
to know they did it if someone you
believe your probable cause to come has
committed a felony possibly they just
killed somebody they just murdered
someone that person and they're in
flight right so they're not waiting for
the cops to show up right they're in
flight they're a
reasonably perceived felon you only
right for the more serious so burglary
is a felony yes
so they believed that at some point this
was a person who committed a burglary
under the statute he was trying to
escape they had grounds to stop him
that's the defense right but the
prosecution said all of these things
have to be true right which makes no
sense which makes no sense no to apply
both standards to apply say all right
every every citizen's arrest no matter
what has to have a hundred percent
certainty and probably but a felony a
felon in flight well that also requires
fifty one percent well
once you have a hundred percent to make
them decide who isn't going through the
level we are here and they don't have
you or to put it another way if the
first sentence applies to everything
including felons in pursuit why do you
need the second sentence right exactly
and
normal statutory interpretation does not
allow you to presume that a substantive
part of a statute is there for no
purpose but i think one of the big
questions was whether or not
probable cause applies to uh
it's it's probably what you're saying i
think what the prosecution argued was
their knowledge from previous incidents
has no bearing on their right to commit
a citizen's arrest today right well she
didn't say it that explicitly but she
would only say what they knew that day
they didn't see anything that looked
like felony burglary that day yep right
because remember she couldn't they
couldn't they the judge prevented her
from using the prosecutor from using the
jogger narrative and yet for what a year
that had already been seated throughout
the community jogger jogger jogger
jogger jogger i mean this notion that he
was just a recreational jogger going
through the neighborhood is ridiculous i
mean because a recreational jogger going
through a neighborhood is not in
someone's home at night repeatedly even
if you were
loitering there was no evidence of
burglary that day if you're in someone's
home in the middle of the night without
any explanation it's reasonable to infer
it's a burglar was he in a house that
night or a house it's it's a house under
construction but it's a house they saw
him exit the house under construction
he's on camera is that what he's in that
night i thought was from an earlier no
earlier earlier nights the cameras from
earlier nights okay so not that because
this event took this event took place
during the day yeah yeah they just saw
him right he was he was right by the
house i guess it sounds like it was
ruled properly
in this instance i mean i don't have all
the data well it's like cole bear
saw him and chased him it sounds sounds
like first of all this definitely should
have shouldn't have happened take
pictures call the police and say
you know we just saw the guy we just saw
the guy he's here i mean that's what i
think most reasonable people would do
but there's a there's a question here
about
man it just something doesn't sit right
with the idea that someone can come into
your community be a burglary suspect
keep going into these homes people are
worried guns go missing and then you
just sit back and say that's that's the
current state of our our country we just
sit back and let this guy do it because
the cops can't stop them thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time